[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
doomsday mom laurie valo daybell deemed
not mentally fit
to stand trial as she awaits murder
charges for the deaths of her two
children
why prosecutors say her religious
beliefs motivated the killings the fate
of an iowa farm worker charged
with killing iowa college student molly
tibbetts now rests in the hands of the
jury
we break down closing arguments in the
trial of christian paneja rivera
there weren't two other guys that's a
figment of his imagination
the so-called central park karen is
suing her former employer
saying she was unfairly fired plus
friends of a woman missing for decades
testify kathy durst was afraid of her
husband the millionaire real estate heir
robert durst and his alleged affair with
prudence pharaoh the inspiration for the
hit beetle song
law and crime daily covering court cases
from coast to coast
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
the so-called doomsday mommy has been
found not fit to stand trial
days after laurie valodebel and her
husband were indicted for the murder of
her two children
and his late wife can you i need you to
speak a little bit louder mr day bell
yes i can hear you lori valo and chad
dabo made their initial appearances
before an idaho judge on wednesday
as a grand jury indicted them for the
first time on murder charges
the court finds that there's some
exigent circumstances as well as
a motion it was made orally to me to
continue the initial appearance
by the defense the couple has been in
jail since last year
on charges of evidence tampering the
bodies of lori's two children were
discovered in june 2020
buried in chad day bell's backyard their
autopsies have not yet been made public
but court records are giving new insight
into why officials believe they were
killed
according to the indictment chad lori
and lori's brother alex cox
conspired to commit murder between 2018
and 2020
officials say they believed in an end of
the world doctrine needing to rid the
world of zombies
and the human bodies they inhabit lori
reportedly met chad in 2018
while chad was teaching in class and
gave her a rubric on light and dark
spirits
both were married at the time in january
2019
gilbert arizona police were called out
to the home lori shared with her then
husband
charles valo body cam video shows
charles vallo
telling officers that laurie had left
with the children
she's lost her mind i i
out of the house to say she said you're
not charles i don't know who you are
what you did with charles but i can
murder you now
with my powers lori and tyler spoke with
police later that day
and said they left because lori caught
charles cheating i got an argument with
my husband on the phone and he was in
texas working and i found some stuff
that he'd been doing so he was really
defensive
and so i took the kids we spent the
night in a hotel because i knew he was
coming home
lori went for a court-ordered mental
health exam and reportedly was cleared
by july charles vallo was dead lori's
brother alex cox said he shot
valo in self-defense what was he yelling
at you about
without my sister because i've broken up
the tussle with them earlier
and he told me not to interfere anymore
with them or i pay and he came at me
with a bat
prosecutors say in august 2019 lori
switched to children's social security
checks to deposit directly
into her own bank account on september
1st 2019
laurie moved to idaho with the kids days
later jj and tyler
had vanished according to the indictment
between september 8th
and 9th chad and laurie encouraged
commanded or compelled another to kill
tiley
around the same time prosecutors say
chad increased the life insurance policy
on his wife tammy dabell then on
september 23rd
prosecutors say alex cox took possession
of jj
it's then the couple is accused of
assisting in the killing of jj
we're now learning that in the beginning
of october 2019
alex cox is accused of trying to shoot
tammy tammy died on october 19
and at the time it was ruled due to
natural causes
two weeks later chad and loy married in
hawaii
in december 2019 alex cox died in his
home
the medical examiner ruled his death due
to natural causes
investigators exhumed tammy's body in
december 2019
and the results of that autopsy have not
yet been made public
prosecutors are now alleging chad had a
role in killing tammy
members of the grand jury deliberated
and determined there is probable cause
to believe the day bells willfully and
knowingly conspired to commit
several crimes that led to the death of
three innocent people
and on thursday a judge stayed lori's
case pending a hearing of her mental
fitness to stand trial
according to a new order her attorney
mark means requested a psychological
assessment of his client in march
a licensed clinical psychologist
determined valodebel is not
competent and recommends restorative
treatment the state is contesting the
report
and a hearing will be scheduled on the
matter
joining us today is criminal defense
attorney mike corebonics
and terry austin terry even the
prosecution is contesting the results
of lori valo dabel's competency results
what do you think of the results
you know i agree with rob wood here he
should contest those results as far as
i'm concerned
when you think about the original
charges against lori that was way back
in february of 2024
the misdemeanor charges for resisting
arrest she could have claimed that
she was not competent at that point or
even the additional charges in june
of 2020 after they found the body saying
that she helped to destroy evidence
so i think it's odd that they just only
recently tried to get a request for our
competency evaluation and in fact
obviously they got it and they found her
incompetent
but i think they saw the writing on the
wall here and i think they're preparing
for these
charges that were you know the
indictment that did come down
mike i can't believe i'm saying this
let's put zombies and viola spirit
aside how is this going to affect lori
and chad's case could the competency
issue
separate the cases and does this create
a change for the prosecution
or defensive strategy it creates a whole
new
a whole new environment in which to
proceed with this case with
so many more really unpredictable
vari variations of what could happen but
i think though if i was the prosecutor
in this case
i would not want to sever or separate
these trials try one person at a time
because although you have all the
discovery in the case all of us here
have tried cases and know
those reports take on a whole new
meaning when you're confronting a
witness
and cross-examining them and based upon
that
it will be very difficult for them to do
this separately because
if they have to wait for lori to get
rule to be competent for trial they
would have had a preview of all the
all the evidence in the first case so i
think they're going to wait
until she's ready to stand and try it
together i mean i think these cases
should be separated
just as the defense attorneys make it
stronger for them so the opposite must
make sense for the prosecution
thank you both still ahead on law and
crime daily the financial firm who fired
the so-called
central park karen is in some hot water
as she's now firing back
but first the jury is deliberating in
the murder of molly tibbett
we break down closing arguments on the
other side of this break
we're back a jury is now deliberating
the fate of an iowa farm worker
accused of killing a college student and
leaving her body in a cornfield
she crossed paths with him
and it ended her life iowa prosecutor
scott brown says christian boneja rivera
murdered mollie tibbetts while she was
out jogging the defendant is accused of
stabbing tibbetts
nine to 12 times shoving her in his
trunk and dumping her body under a pile
of corn
molly is threatening to call the police
and the defendant was angry he says that
he tells us that he also says when he
gets angry blacks out
that's what he claims that's what he
told the police the defendant whenever
they talk to him
they say take us to her and he does turn
by turn
takes him right there the defense told
the jury that molly's death was tragic
but their client is not the real killer
they say investigators couldn't solve
the case for weeks
and singled out vane rivera
no murder weapon ever was discovered in
this case
they don't have an eyewitness but we
dispute greatly
that what they attribute to christian
bahina as a statement
can be characterized as a confession
this man
five foot seven inch 125 pound
illegal immigrant undocumented immigrant
gets
angry and resorts to killing her
stabbing her nine times
the evidence we do have about christian
bahana is that he's not an angry man
he's a family man he's hard working
he came to this country for a reason and
you can bet
he wanted to stay in this country
before the jury heard closing arguments
the state called one last witness in
rebuttal
angela levy has that and more from
christian bohena rivera's testimony
christian bahina rivera's defense team
has named molly tibbetts
boyfriend as a potential suspect in her
murder so the state
called dalton jack's supervisor to
testify about his alibi
it was dalton jack on the crew that was
working in dubuque
on the bridge that crossed the river yes
he was
nick wilson testified he and dalton jack
and their crew were more than two hours
away from brooklyn iowa the night molly
tibbetts was last seen alive
did you and your crew including dalton
jack go anywhere
after work on sev at 7 pm on july 18th
of 2018.
no it did not did you go back to the
hotel
yes all right and did dalton jack go
with you
yes he did the defense says dalton jack
gave different statements to law
enforcement
about what he did that night so you're
not sure if he was in his room
it's hard to remember it was three years
ago christian bahina rivera testified
two men forced him to drive around the
night tibbetts disappeared
after appearing in his trailer and
sweaters and masks
one of them was bigger and a little bit
fatter and one of them was about my
stature
and a little bit stronger burly
the hana rivera testified the masked men
took off
after leaving him in a cornfield with
mollie tibbetts in the trunk
barely alive he admitted he placed her
body in the cornfield
do you remember being asked in the
interview by
ms romero if you were covering for
anyone
yes christian bahina rivera testified
that he never mentioned those two masked
men to the police
because they threatened to kill his
ex-girlfriend and their daughter
if he said anything for law and crime
daily i'm angelette levy
thanks anjanet let's bring back kimwill
defense attorney mike corebonics
and terry austin to break this all down
mike did the rebuttal witness
have any impact for you and do you think
the prosecution
maybe either did a misstep or a good
calculation in calling them
i i think in the way this case was going
forward this was a good witness to call
for rebuttal
because it really eliminated someone it
said you know they could talk about this
potential suspect all they want but he
had nothing to do with it so i thought
it was a good move
yeah now terry did the defense's closing
argument
leave you with any reasonable doubt or
should we just be waiting for sentencing
you know based on the closing i have no
doubt but i think there might just be a
juror
who has some doubt and that could
actually
you know lead to not having a conviction
here so
the defense's argument basically was
that the
prosecution had unlimited resources so
why didn't they
look at other leads that they had no
motive
that the defendant had no motive and of
course he did have a motive he himself
said that he got angry
the defense also said there was no
evidence and there was evidence there
was a ton of evidence there was blood in
the trunk so of course there's evidence
so i think that he's making these
arguments you know one other argument he
made was that
the interrogation was 11 hours long but
none of that negates the fact that
it was his client he put the body
in the cornfield he said he did that he
showed them where the body was so
i have no doubt but there might just be
one juror who does
and you'll need just one for a hung jury
and that could be exactly what the
defensive attorney is trying to do
like as a defender you know that you
just got to get one right i mean do you
think they can find just one here
i think so i think they can i think this
defense attorney was very creative
he did a great job of separating all the
circumstances
and taking it apart the only problem is
when you pull the circumstances together
the case seems much more solid with the
confession
all right let's see how this plays out
like we said the jury is still
deliberating
coming up on law and crime daily former
neighbors of robert durst testify in
court
about the real estate heirs missing wife
plus
the so-called central park karen is now
suing for racial discrimination
we break down the lawsuit against her
former employer next
welcome back the so-called central park
karen is filing a lawsuit against her
former employer
alleging racial discrimination
amy cooper went viral in may 2020 for
calling the cops on a black bird watcher
she's now suing her former employer
franklin templeton
for unlawful termination the suit says
cooper called police because the man
christian cooper was a quote overzealous
bird watcher
who targeted miss cooper in a feud
between bird watchers
and dog lovers not because of his race
she was fired the next day
but claims she was not interviewed
before being let go
the financial firms say they are
sticking by their initial statement
which says
they do not tolerate racism of any kind
she is seeking an unspecified amount of
money for damages
emotional distress negligence and racial
discrimination
a misdemeanor charge of false reporting
was dropped after cooper completed
restorative justice sessions
all right back to discuss this lawsuit
by the so-called central park karen
is defense attorney mike corobonix and
co-host terry austin
terry disgruntled employee or wrongfully
unterminated what do you think
you know i think it's a well-written
complaint but i don't think it's going
to
succeed you know she's suing for race
discrimination and she's not in a
protected class and even if she were
suing
for reverse discrimination she'd have to
show that the decision
made really was made in contrast to
how the firm handled those not in her
class or category so i don't think that
they will be able to do that and i
haven't seen that in the complaint they
mentioned one person but that was it
she's also suing for harassment and i
don't think terminating someone
uh just that's alone is going to be
successful for harassment
she's singing for gender and you know i
she'll again have to show that there
were multiple people
men who weren't treated like that and
she's also suing for defamation and of
course you have to show
that what was said was false and that
the company knowingly made this false
statement so
well-written complaint but i don't as
yet
see the facts supporting the allegations
yeah
i would tend to agree as well let me let
me follow up with this one with you
terry
um i don't see the racial discrimination
but maybe it's an issue
that the employer didn't check all of
the boxes before firing her so it could
be a procedural issue
rather than a racial issue you know it
could be a procedural
issue but if they didn't follow their
handbook
then and that's it that's a problem but
unless they can show
that they followed the handbook with
other people in
other categories beyond her category
then
it's not an issue so you know i don't
think that even that failure to
abide by their own policy is going to
result in anything now what she might be
trying to do is get a settlement
and they could very well do that before
they take it all the way
exactly and i think with a lot of these
things in new york as we both
know it tends to be an at-will
employment in the state so if it's at
will
they might not need to follow any
procedures just say hey you got arrested
for
a crime of dishonesty and we want you to
go but
we'll keep eyes on this case and see how
it plays out thank you very much terry
when we come back we head to california
where the neighbors of kathy and robert
durst testify
was a millionaire real estate air having
an affair when his wife went missing
[Music]
welcome back luna real estate air robert
durst is on trial
for the murder of his longtime friend
susan berman in december 2000
prosecutors allege that berman knew
about the death of durst's first wife
kathy who has been missing since the
1980s
and that he killed berman because she
could go to the police friends of the
duress say
he was having an affair with prudence
pharaoh the woman who's the inspiration
for the beatles song
dear prudence prosecutors also asked if
durst was violent towards kathy in 1981
i wasn't until she told me okay so i
don't want you to tell me specifically
what she told you
but i want to know did you have
conversations with her about it
yes okay and you became aware of it yes
and what period of time was this that
was the summer of
1981. did you encourage
kathy to do something about this
violence she was telling you about
i did what did you encourage her to do
she didn't want to report it and i
encouraged her to do so
on cross the defense asked mayor about
robert durst's behavior
after kathy disappeared
my husband saw am i was in my pajamas so
i heard the whole thing but i didn't see
him
so he wanted to know if you folks knew
where his wife was yes because you were
a logical
couple to ask since you lived next door
correct yes
and if you were missing you'd expect
your husband to have gone over to the
durst and asked
have you seen my wife correct yes
so there was nothing unusual about bob
coming over to ask for help
was there well i it's hard for me to say
it wasn't unusual
because well not putting aside whatever
you've read
and whatever you think and whatever
position you have
at the time it would not have been
unusual for a husband to come next door
and ask you for help trying to find his
wife
correct yeah okay
all right let's bring in to mike
corbonis and terry austin one last time
mike this is all still very
circumstantial
is any of this at least for you creating
a path to guilt or
innocence i'm looking for the path
to relevance this case has been
i don't even if you just listen to the
case you don't even know who the victim
was because it seems like it was
durst first wife i don't understand this
case and how
the rules of evidence and this judge is
allowing all these kind of
opinions by lay witnesses in this kind
of like
asking her like what would your husband
do and did he
come to you i just don't see the
relevance in this case and i don't see
why the prosecution wants to have all
these built-in appeals
relevance confusion of the of the jury
potentially
terry microrobotics is kind of touching
on potential appellate issues
i think the defense is probably thinking
about those grounds as well do you see
any viable arguments on appeal
if durst is found guilty well i think
mike just hit the nail on the head
there's no question
that getting all of this evidence about
kathy durst
about the fact that morris black was
killed and he was
you know durst acquitted of that about
all of these other
unrelated issues as it relates to
why we are here now we are here now
because of the murder
of susan berman so i think that that is
a ground for appeal and i also think
the fact that we had a jury months ago
18 months ago and they
waited and they're brought back that is
a huge ground for
appeal as far as i'm concerned the fact
that they're not going to remember what
happened and
listening to this evidence again it is a
huge ground
i think to move if in fact there's just
found guilty
for appeal of this trial it's just got
so many errors
yeah i agree with you both i keep
thinking this is an appellate issue this
isn't a palette issue that's an
appellate issue
and not to sign horrible about it it may
be a moot issue because will
robert durst make it through that appeal
not quite sure
terry mike thank you very much and thank
you for joining us here on law and crime
daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
you